decision on the variation of the
application to the premises license at
veto's 184 ashley road sale
we're going to allow the variation
application to the hours as amended
tonight
by the applicant which are
a
reduction of hours on sales to midnight
each evening
with 30 minutes to closing time
and the reduction of off sales to 2300
each evening
the condition of a dedicated email
address for neighbors
to contact me to contact the
applicant
the front of the premise is to be to be
swept clean
uh on a regular basis
keep the passageway between the two
properties clear at all times
on the in the
collection and disposal would be no
collection and disposal of refuse
between twenty thirty hundred hours and
oh eight hundred hours
and no bottles to be thrown into the
bins during this time
um
further to the request to be personally
notified um
in the licensing of all licensing
applications
we have to adhere to
the legislation for licensing
authorities
um to
to consult
in the in the way that's set out so it
wouldn't be possible
basically to notify individuals about
changes to the licensing
um
you know that would be done in the usual
way um and if there was a significant
change then anybody
in that vicinity who came under that
that scope of legislation would then be
notified
so we would encourage uh ms marshall to
speak to the applicant using the uh
the email that's provided and and of
course the phone
uh phone number given and try and avert
any any issues um before they obviously
become a major issue
so
we'd encourage obviously
to communicate with each other the
applicant and the uh on the
representative
um and
we wish you every success
both sides every success really with the
future and uh hope you can
happily coexist with each other
you will be
given the the reasons that the the aptly
sorry the
result in writing uh within five working
days
um with the reasons given
so with that i'd like to thank everybody
for attending tonight
and i will officially close the meeting
so uh thank you and good night
thank you
thank you